hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play attack on
Titan now I have to preface this because
otherwise people will go crazy
so attack on Titan is a recent anime
that has been made that is oh well I
just got body slammed by a big meaty
fist my day is not complete until that
happened but anyway attack on Titan
which I should probably haha I'm in
pieces all over the ground I didn't even
start playing yet how do i oh you're big
ain't ya you're really big how do I
respawn you gotta tell me how to or do I
only get one life and it never there we
go I think I hit T I believe so anyway
this is um this is attack on Titan I
only played it a little bit I like I
like TPS camera stuff and it's one of
the recent animes now I do not watch a
lot of anime I just don't walk what the
hell are you doing what the hell is
wrong with you you gonna come ballet
over here body slam oh that totally
missed me I wasn't even near him/her wow
you killed yourself body slamming that
was okay anyway I do not watch a lot of
anime I'm the most I've watched is like
Dragon Ball Z back on Toonami on Cartoon
Network I'm pretty sure everyone can
vouch for me that that was an awesome
time in TV for cartoons and let me like
try to get on a building and try not to
get from away from the ramp and
ballerinas over here hello mister anyway
I played it a little bit I'm it's CUNY
to launch your little ropey thingies and
you can press shift to no get up there
you can press shift when you're on a
there's no top of this building I might
be in bit oh my god it's the ballerina
again we're gonna hang here and look
through my crotch just for a little bit
of these guys you're tall angel let's
see oh almost got me now anyway besides
Dragon Ball Z and like Full Metal
Alchemist which I really like and some
of the movies like Princess Mononoke and
spirited away I don't watch a lot but
attack on Titan has been one that has
been really interesting lately but the
premise is ah God he sploded me he
sploded me all over the ground
the premise is you're trying to fight
these Titans which are have invaded
earth and are trying to eat all of
humanity for some strange reason and
their various sizes I don't know what
that is over there but I'm gonna find
out and the only way that the humans
have been able to fight him is whoa that
did not do what I wanted it to do what
are you what did I just get
oh you weirdo you freaking weirdo I'm
gonna hang on and you kill them
oh he's bowing all over me he's playing
oh oh I don't feel right it's weird
oh I wasn't even near it okay anyway
that guy is a freak on wheels and
apparently in the anime there are some
deviants like that I think they call him
and they're just a bunch of weirdos
they're just a bunch of weirdos that no
go up that building all right I'm gonna
try to get up a building because so far
I've just been tightened food that guys
really bake no he's standing on the
building over there so he's a cheater
he's not really that tall anyway you're
in a city full of these weird blobby
turd monsters that are just giant bags
of flesh they like to eat humans I mean
who doesn't that sounds good anyway it's
really interesting premise for a show
but uh you see those spots on the back
of their necks which what you need to
chop into in order to kill them and this
is actually a pretty I'm actually
surprised at how fun this game is
because then I just start zooming on
know who ah about a gunshot I'm gonna go
close I'm gonna get you big boy Oh
nailed you ah it's a derp derp oh I'm
gonna call them the dirt the dirt are
done smashed me into the ground I
haven't been able to get more than one
apparently because I suck I don't even
know what character from the show I'm
playing I don't know their names if the
show isn't even dubbed yet so you gotta
like you gotta you gotta watch the
Japanese version if you want to see it
for yourself it's really cool I would
highly recommend it and I don't
recommend things off and excuse me do
you want a knife to the back of the ah
I'm cool I'm turned into a rocket
shup blood rocket just spurting through
the sky nope okay alright so maybe I'm
not doing this right maybe I got a sweet
talking over here I'll pick on the
little guy oh you're not much taller
than I am
come here sweet Wow trace swath no get
up higher
jump jump stab at their ankles oh come
on I can't even handle the little ones
maybe if I just poke them in the ankle
with my sword they'll fall over
eventually and then I'll be able to kill
them okay I'm gonna ride for the neck
right for the neck oh I forgot about the
dancing weirdo ah
got ya yeah I'm the best ever kind of
maybe maybe not ooh hello oh are you
flirting with me oh you know I'm
susceptible though belly flops aren't
that sexy bro just trying to tell you
that right now okay let me go up get
higher I'm gonna sweep down and then
there's a whole lot of yeah am I
supposed to kill them all how am I
supposed to do that
all right I'm gonna I'm gonna Dominus
I'm gonna jump down and then epically oh
yeah go right up through that crotch
that's what they like the fastest way to
a Titans heart is through its crotch and
there we go that was it's actually they
they loved me a little too much and now
the evidence of their love is splattered
me all over the god that sounded way
dirtier than I wanted it to me I'm
coming right for you big boy come here
Oh it about you to swallow yeah I'm on
fire you gonna get some well get oh you
got a little too much of me I didn't
want you to have that much god I still
don't know what those things do so
apparently I still suck at this game and
Titan left there's 32 damn Titans how in
the world am I supposed to be 32
freaking Titan No jump jump jump I aah
you miss me you big ugly goof I like
your buck teeth good for chomping the
heads off of humans no I haven't had one
try to eat me all they do is small right
into his crotch
all they've tried to do is smash me how
is that gonna help you with your diet
yeah you're all looking a little too
chubby anyway I'm coming right for you
big boy once again the stellar awesome
super mega attack I can jump up
buildings I can't I can't seem to jump
up these guys it's not working
forget it you know what forget it I'm
gonna assume that I'm about out here by
myself because my teammates wanted me to
die so I just need to die honorably so
that you guys don't have anything to
complain about later oh sweet dodge
moves I know I'm I'm a professional
Titan killer I'm a professional Titan
feeder if this was dota people would be
flagging me in reporting no no no I
don't taste good I'm all bones oh he ate
me and I'm just staring through their
flabby bodies they're kind of grody
they're kind of empty where's my with my
other body in this guy but no well
that's weird
okay so there's too many of them I don't
know what I'm supposed to do it's just
too many of them and even if I do this I
don't know what that's supposed to do
that doesn't really yeah I'm gonna climb
up the raw you freaky freaky freaky
deaky I'm gonna just climb up this wall
cuz I'm tired of these guys screw these
guys I'm gonna see whether it's the top
of this thing
yep go go go I don't know don't ask me
how I'm able to run straight up
vertically for a few feet and then do a
sweet backflip move but don't complain
you just jelly these jelly of my epic
moves whatever gender I may or may not
be I have no idea I'm kind of
androgynous at this point but who cares
is there a top to this there we go okay
there it is okay and almost there no
whoa wait what get back here yep oh oh
yeah you're joking me oh you're joking
me okay ah at least I'm away from those
[ __ ] I wonder if I can take fall
damage here huh I'm coming for ya big
boy
oh no no fall damage here wait this is
perfect
you stay no no no ha ha ha you thought
you could get me oh that one's gonna get
me ah
and I'm splattered all over the ground
again mmm this games hard most likely
because in the show there wasn't much
there wasn't much of a success rate in
these shows I have to admit coming right
for your neck oh don't turn around I
know I'm beautiful but you don't have to
look at me the whole time no don't do
whatever you're doing you small 100
didn't get me I thought for sure can I
jump why can I never jump when I want to
jump and what do these things do oh no
what did I just get what did I just get
oh did I get like more swords ow that
hurt a lot okay whatever I get a power
they're so hard that's what she said
they're so big you smashed me too hard
that's what she said okay I think I'm
done because obviously I'm not getting
any better at this game in fact patently
I think I'm getting worse because it's
been a long time since I got a kill
don't turn around don't turn around
don't turn what was that over there oh
my god got a bug you shouldn't be
worried about me man you really
shouldn't haha oh you should've been
more hurry you should have been worried
about me you thought you didn't need to
be worried about oh come on it was right
there No
yeah I got to get me out of here oh
please please dear God get me out of
here
I'm scooting along my along my butt
along the ground oh there's so many
that's what she said oh man okay
I don't know how I'm gonna be able to
take on all of these that's okay I need
I'm gonna stop that
hi hey buddy you missed me I'm not on
your chest I'm gonna jump over your head
and then do an epic squeak yeah
I got 300 okay it's okay it's okay
oh my god four oh I had that what are
you doing I had that there we go got
four all right I'm doing pretty good
surprisingly I'm gonna shoot behind him
and then do a sick move where I no no
what did you grab down to the ground
that over the woman's work
yeah yeah yeah sweet moves bro it's just
hitting yeah I'll play they got five I'm
doing fantastically I thought I was
doing horribly but now all the sudden
I'm doing amazing oh you're right for
the nevermind no you're not that way you
probably be greatly concerned about that
over there no right up his butt oh no
what he went back he wasn't even going
for me he was going to scratch the crack
of his ass and then he just happened to
grab on to me is that what she said cuz
I don't know that wasn't kind of weird
but anyway I think I'm done for now
there's no way that I'm gonna be getting
all these so you can play this for
yourself totally free available online
made on the Unity engine by the way but
I didn't mention that before if you want
to check out attack on Titan I'm not
gonna force anyone I I'm not one of
those guys are saying like you have to
watch there's anime you must watch dan
moves and I I couldn't care less if you
like it or not just some shows are good
sometimes you're not so take it with a
grain of salt don't judge people for
light and what they don't let though
thank you everybody so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video
No
I'm not exactly